[Music]
in crypto duped news what happened
Steve probably knows submitted by JK
visits Thailand okay me like this video
if you want us to go right now
they have a huge crypto presence there
in Thailand video I really want to go I
haven't been in Thailand for like 20
years
you went 20 years ago yeah I went I was
it was pretty cool yeah when you were 20
20 years ago yeah that means you're not
20 now whoa that's old dude 20 years ago
it was dope dude like food was great it
a lot of the food smelled like dog
really like a dog's hair oh I was eating
like [ __ ] food that should make me
sick but and none of it made me sick
yeah that's the only Street [ __ ]
vendor all that [ __ ] and I went like
past the tourist place into the cuts oh
yeah that [ __ ] was dope time okay give
me a coke dude knows I'm a young actor
was arrested after fooling a man out of
24 million in Bitcoin 2000 24 million oh
how do you [ __ ] a new fool someone for
24 billion dollars like hey I'm like
kind of acting like a broker like hey
you got a we got us all startup the oh
hold yours crypto stuff's going nowhere
we go so and then the guy who gives them
all is crypto yep oh my god his um his
passwords are some [ __ ] and just
transferred all the [ __ ] off yeah all
the crypto needed [ __ ] shut up if he
made a [ __ ] ton on crypto like Jesus
yeah so this story so the actor he's a
popular Thai actor who's been in movies
and TV shows
he goes by boom
so he's a 24 million yeah in Thailand
No so no BIC the Bitcoin was we haven't
even for millions says when he was
getting arrested while he was filming up
for a movie why they blow out the hand
talk that's the thief that's the actor
yeah why is that blurred out it's like
uh we don't have them under arrest guys
that is weird
it's like it won't shame him maybe
that's interesting huh does that
blurring the face they blur the handcuff
they do that to with like putting a
t-shirt over the cuffs sometimes you've
seen that oh yeah but it's like it's not
a mystery dude we know what the [ __ ] is
going on always like that that's what I
love about that yeah I like the dildos
that blurred out oh yeah so it's PR
people being like just don't just blur
the handcuffs yeah right so this dude
and two of his siblings siblings two of
his siblings yeah anyway brother and
sister look what you did I know in self
conscious know the two siblings I heard
him we love you TIFF I didn't say [ __ ] I
want to know this guy and his brother
and sister
okay siblings they do you were this
Finnish victim who's a 22 year old he
transferred 5560 for bitcoins to their
he wallets claiming that it was payment
for shares of three firms but he says
that he never received the shares to
those firms after the transfer so he
called the Thai authorities and filed a
complaint at six months after he made
the transfer that money's gone
yeah who's gone as [ __ ] six months after
what a dumb [ __ ] are you kidding me so
they blew it all do you does he have
like a [ __ ] ton more Bitcoin at least I
hope so I do too what what what is it
like he's trying to buy three calm
shares in three companies but he didn't
even look into the companies or anything
I mean he must have money to Poland but
I mean nobody willing to spend that much
money or he could have gotten scanned
you have a crypto rich people are some
of the dumbest people on earth could
have been people that didn't even know
weren't even related to those companies
that scammed him like saying like oh I
work for Google and Disney and stuff
give me here they were saying that they
were making investments and the dragon
coin cryptocurrency Oh God okay so it's
his total [ __ ] coin oppress so so okay
they had been arrested for money
laundering hmm and what was your
question so did they get caught like
using a bunch of money they got caught
because of the Finnish victim reported
and reported it so that's funny they
didn't even use that alias like they
just [ __ ] told him who they really
were
I don't know that's ridiculous and he's
already they might have met in person
he's an actor like he's God well don't
they get your information from your you
will it no they don't
it's a that's the whole point of crypto
it's all that's a me it's not all like
private per se if there's some privacy
coins like Manero and stuff but by and
large it's tough to track mmm is it
possible that they did the deal in
person so he knows exactly who it is but
even if they did that his money's still
gone yeah yeah yeah at least they can
arrest them
Danny get the money back so what they're
saying is that the authorities seized
property various plots of land which
they both authorities believe that they
they just went shopping sprees of the
scam and but in a country like that
evening it's possible the government to
just torture them to get the password
out because we can't do that here
Thailand's pretty civilized man are they
yeah yeah so when the oldest brother he
possesses more than 3.3 million dollars
in his bank account and then the eldest
sister she has about 4.2 million dollars
in her account and then this actor we're
talking about he possesses
six hundred and forty nine thousand
dollars they burn oh man so he went all
in that there were other bank accounts
of alleged members they're calling them
gang members I don't know if they really
mean like banking but anyway the members
here and they're saying that they
contain amounts ranging between two
million and four point nine million
dollars so it's all spread out yeah
because they're oh that's why it's the
money laundering the bank accounts
belonging to 51 other people that have
been also frozen in this anti money
laundering
damn that's a pretty crazy Network full
of people to pull this off so the cat
who had is the cat who gave twenty
million he only has six hundred DG's
left and that got frozen no the six
hundred fifty G's is the actor actor he
was on that dupe he was a main guy i'll
hidup the victim yeah because that's
that guy boom he's saying that his
siblings just used his bank accounts and
that he had nothing to do with this
he's the only one that's been arrested
and they did let him out on bail because
his siblings are sibling stop she's got
over I know you called me out you get
out you say you know what am I saying
just siblings siblings siblings what do
we think I believe I believe yes as I BL
I be a bling siblings siblings yeah it
does even matter I said the way I say
whatever you want yeah you can say
someone see me going back ever you see
me stuff you pointed out how much I felt
edit yes and you're gonna be part of
this cop no I don't want to I'm sorry
too I love you too it's all because they
put putting it out and not yet not here
yeah I'm not hearing not doing the bid I
have to join the bed always you know
like that I love that I love a sibling
in pets empowering that's the way you
want to sub alone oh yeah you're poking
bilingual alright yeah exactly
oh yeah the way you want tonight I'm
gonna be made out of diamond you
shattered that weight class our diamond
supposably I always set the puzzle right
you say supposedly but that's the right
way yeah but that wasn't self-editing
that ain't nailed saying suppose it's
right supposably supposably is right no
all the time no there's not yeah but no
I hope you stupid job all the time
stupid I could call scoop it all the
time because it's like a funny thing
it's not like a legit oh we don't think
you're stupid
you guys don't okay yeah okay but now
they're gonna see always hate you shut
up a lot of people that think that's my
friend they also think that we're
actually arguing when we're not arguing
- there's only and they think we're
flirting with each other significant
others amazing so that's why did they
put Steve next to Joe maybe Steve and
Nikki are fighting yeah you guys are
right by the way when Steve NGOs back
that was a little weird like you didn't
like it you could tell it's all real
read into all of it cuz it's real love
why they doing it cuz they're [ __ ]
yeah it's cuz they just got hormones in
there that's yeah cuz they want to have
sex you know that's pretty much what
their thing anyway yeah dude
the crypto people who are I'm telling
you a lot of crypto millionaires are
some of the dumbest people ever because
they just kind of got lucky right like
they they put in 100 bucks or whatever
in 2010 and now they have 50 mil and
it's like that money go though people
cannot hold onto their month money yep
it's gonna blow and this guy probably is
like okay I got 25 million like if I
make a good move
I could turn into send to a hundred I
can really upgrade my lifestyle is like
my my lifestyle upgraded from when I was
poor so now I'm rich you know I want
that [ __ ] jet setter lifestyle win
the lottery and they lose their money
all right away because they don't know
how to you know have money a guy like
this
you wanna invest in Dragon coin and then
he's like yeah about 25 that's crazy I
want to know someone like that right why
I invest in Joe Mallya Klein sure 30
million and I'll be so if it was last
year you probably could have done it
crazy last year during the ico crazy you
could have done that [ __ ] I don't know I
feel Joe Mallya coin and probably driven
that [ __ ] up to a buck each after being
like penniless that would have been cool
yeah that's what a lot of a lot of
different crypto oh she's gonna be okay
Cooper's gonna be okay just hold on just
huddle huddle guys for dear life way to
say huddle way to say hold I first found
Bitcoin it was well it was like 1,000
each or whatever and then that she went
to 150 each dog so this all its had
1,000 eat for like years well no I went
through my mom told me it was a hundred
dollars yeah yeah that's right man from
a thousand dollars it went yeah and then
it took it took like three years and
then it built way back up in blow way
past a thousand hit two thousand then I
hit [ __ ] twenty thousand so yeah but
the market keeps growing yeah that's the
thing is people only see the last six
months of crypto right now cuz most
people got in 2017 yeah so they don't
see the big picture but the real deal is
the market is still above what it's been
oh yeah it's I mean it's not it's not
where it was in january/february right
but it but it's above like like this
time of Hazzard's yeah ten years or
whatever yeah but the big deal the media
doesn't say that [ __ ] they say like
bitcoins over and people are committing
suicide the window when the financial
institution money goes in that's when
the
real [ __ ] gonna you know 50,000 coinbase
users a day there this is a conspiracy
or the theory is that that those
institutions are driving the price down
right now so that they can buy it and in
Pat vehement being a power player is
neatly and the other conspiracy is that
they're doing an off-market right so
like what Bart was saying earlier where
it's like you just meet with somebody
and you sell your Bitcoin to them like
you don't do it on the exchange yeah so
it doesn't drive the price up on the
exchange so you just send it so you can
still short the market while you buy a
bunch of Bitcoin and accumulate a bunch
of Bitcoin off market homie and it
doesn't log in any of the exchanges yeah
that's right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]